riddled with graphic sensuality and
violence saltburn left a serious mark on
the 2023 film scene to its very last
frame this is the truth about salt bur's
shocking conclusion and beware there are
spoilers ahead saltburn opens in what
appears to be roughly the present day
with Oliver quick reflecting on his
relationship with Felix katten the film
then flashes back to when the two first
met at Oxford in 2006 like most students
at the University Felix comes from
wealth whereas Oliver is one of the f
students there on scholarship supposedly
Oliver's alcoholic father has passed
away and Oliver has no interest in
coming home to his drug addicted mother
feeling bad for his new friend Felix
invites Oliver to spend the summer at
saltburn his family's lavish estate at
saltburn Oliver is introduced to Felix's
family his absent-minded father Sir
James his snobby mother elth and his
depressed and Bic sister Venicia also
living at soulburn is Felix's cousin
Farley start Farley is a biracial
American who's desperate to cling to to
his British family status and already
has an antagonistic relationship with
Oliver at school Oliver is obsessed with
Felix and when Venicia and faray both
Tred to make it clear to him that Felix
just sees him as a temporary toy to play
with Oliver responds by messing with
both of them in perverse ways in the
Final Act of the film The Kat and family
prepares a big birthday bash for Oliver
themed around the midsummer night stream
but Felix becomes wise to Oliver's
manipulations the morning before the
party Felix takes Oliver on a surprise
visit to Oliver's parents house contrary
to Oliver's sub stories both of his
parents are alive friendly middle class
and seemingly not addicts at the party
Felix is put off by Oliver's dishonesty
and doesn't want to be anywhere near him
even so Oliver tracks him down in salb
bur's Labyrinth to declare his love
after the party Felix's body is found
dead in The Labyrinth Sir James and elth
try to act like everything's okay but
venisha and F can't keep up the
ridiculous facade well you want me just
to eat it like nothing's happening what
else is there to do darling anything
after the funeral Oliver essentially has
sex with Felix's grave not long after
her brother's death fenicia commits
suicide and while El Beth wants to keep
Oliver around Sir James wants to pay
their guests to leave saltburn years
pass and the film brings us back to the
present day sir James dies and an older
Oliver reunites with elth she welcomes
him back to saltburn with open arms but
sure enough she falls ill and ends up on
life support it's revealed that Oliver's
opening narration was being delivered to
an incapacitated elth ol confesses that
he killed Felix by poisoning his drink
before ripping away elest life support
with the whole caten family destroyed
soulburn is now in Oliver's possession
he celebrates by doing cocaine and
dancing naked around the building the
premise of saltburn makes it seem easy
to compare it to the recent wave of dark
satires about the halves and have nuts
such as parasite or the menu however
saltburn finds material to laugh about
in The Eccentric fireballs and
uncomfortably callous attitudes of the
ultra wealthy curtains its attitude
toward or the upper class feels a lot
less vicious than other films of this
type the reason for this is largely
because its ultimate villain isn't a
rich person or a greater systemic Force
instead it's Oliver a middle class
interloper whatever sympathy Oliver
might initially engender as an outsider
is lost due to both his Twisted actions
and lack of psychological relatability
viewing salurn as a commentary on class
the fact that Oliver lies about being
poor and struggling when he is really
just envious of those who have more than
he does might even come across as a
reactionary message none Le some critics
have still described the film as an Eat
the Rich movie the logic here is that
even if Oliver comes off as more
sociopathic than his wealthy hosts
people can still find enjoyment and
seeing him slowly destroy those silly
out of touch curtain and claim Soul burn
for himself it's important to
acknowledge that salurn takes place in
England where issues of class are
treated differently than they are in
America while American capitalism is
based on the idea of the American dream
where anyone from any background can
make it big if they work hard enough
British class structures are treated
with a much more rigid line between
casts this is particularly visible in
institutions like Oxford where a
scholarship students like Oliver
completely sticks out I mean you're
almost passing for
what I don't know in that cultural
context it's possible Brit may feel even
greater catharus seeing Oliver find ways
to rise above his station regardless of
the Twisted methods through which he
goes about it in America however stories
of people attaining massive amounts of
wealth through controversial methods are
both common and popular so this aspect
of the film plays a bit more basic and
less richly satisfying across the pond
throughout the film saltburn
acknowledges this culture Clash through
the American character of Farley one of
the more complex supporting characters
in the film Farley bullies Oliver to
assert his connections to privilege
within the British class structure but
Farley's position is very much
conditional and his hyper privileged
family still treats him as an outsider
there's no doubt this is due to his
biracial status for wild class
hierarchies are slightly less ingrained
in the American psyche racial
hierarchies are fixed in place on both
sides of the Atlantic well saltburn
invokes a lot of conversations about
social class the main source of drama in
the film is Oliver's feelings for Felix
in the film's opening narration Oliver
claims he loved Felix but wasn't in love
with him both Oliver and Felix talk of
love for each other throughout the film
and at least in Oliver's case that goes
beyond seeing Felix as good friends and
into a clear homoerotic sexual fixation
in the end Oliver declares he actually
hated Felix that his feelings lies he
drove him to wreak havoc on the caten
clan of course there's much to debate
over what exactly Oliver considers love
he comes across as a complete sociopath
lacking empathy towards others and
showing no hesitation about cruy
manipulating the people around him for
this reason he may be entirely incapable
of love as it's traditionally defined
whether or not his feelings can be
accurately Called Love however he's
certainly filled with passion and
Obsession in addition to the sexual
attraction he feels for Felix much of
his desire for his friend is rooted in
Envy Oliver wants Felix's social status
wealth and his effortless ability to
charm everyone around him in the end
Oliver is able to take all of Felix's
former belongings for his own but
gaining his victim's personal strengths
is another matter entirely with such a
psychologically ambiguous protagonist
saltburn genuinely aims to shock and
Intrigue more than build a deeper
connection between the audience and its
characters even so there is one scene
towards the end of the film that stands
out by letting more genuine emotion
enter the picture what's more the
sequence also doubles as the film's most
pointed joke about the British upper
class the morning that Felix has been
found dead Sir James and ELP still
refuse to let go of their pre-existing
plans despite their son's death gathered
at the dining room table the parents
just want to talk about how great
Oliver's birthday party was while eating
meat Pi in contrast F and Venicia
reacted the death with actual tears when
F tries to talk about how absurd and
cruel it is to act as if nothing
happened the parents respond with orders
to quietly eat his lunch and not take
the meal with his emotions none of us
wants your bloody American feelings the
parents represent the stoic attitude to
keep calm and carry on to a comically
unhealthy extreme even outside of
specific cultural context this scene
hits hard due to the universal struggle
to pretend things are normal in the face
of tragedy given the conscious need to
avoid spoilers about the film's many
twists the cast and crew of soulburn
haven't spoken directly about the film's
ending as of the end of 2023 however
Emerald Fel has commented on the general
themes of the film offering some helpful
insight into how to process a film's
ending in addition to the topic she
doesn't outright comment on when
speaking to Vogue the filmmaker avoided
answering questions about the way the
film addresses racism sexism and
classism deeming these political issues
secondary to her actual main focus she
explained really it's a film about First
Love generally because I'm quite facile
I think everything has to do with sex
and I think our fantasization of the
country house and titles is completely
sedom masochistic she went on to discuss
some of the complexities of humanity
that inspired the film saying I'm
utterly obsessed with how we relate to
things that we want and desire and also
kind of hate and know are unattainable
things that we know will never love us
back whether that's a person or a house
or a culture and yet we can't stop being
desperately attracted to them my
question is why imagery over Oliver's
climactic and Midsummer Night's Dream
birthday party has been present
throughout the marketing for saltburn so
while the dramatic events of the party
are still spoiler material the film crew
has been able to speak about the design
elements of the sequence in the Press
noes for the Film Production designer
Susie Davies explained there were so
many design elements that we wanted to
bring to the party elements that needed
to feel like they'd been in the family
for years Davis went on to explain the
choice to include the Fairly out of
place image of a pig roasting on a spit
at the lavish Affair saying and then to
contrast that we talked about having the
slightly grotesque Pig on the spit
rolling in front of it it was all about
the Jer position of the surreal the
Sinister and the colorful costume
designer Sophie Canali also opened up
about Oliver's anid costume explaining
that it came from a desire to make him
look mythical she also pointed out the
contrast between the intensely jeweled
designs of Venicia and elest costumes
against Felix's lazier Puck costume
saying you've got everyone else at the
party in ball gowns Black Tie fancy
dress or trashy dresses but Felix is
just in his jeans and a vest and then
he's put a pair of wings on and that's
all the effort he's going to make
speaking in the Press nose before the
SAG after strike Archie MC Dei who
played faray in the film described the
dramatic effect the party has on the
story he observed throughout the film
there's something of a heightened
Shakespearean quality to Salt bur and
the CN and then it all comes to life on
this night another key to understanding
salurn is its connections to Gothic
romance and horror stories fennel cited
several Gothic novels like daffany de
morier Rebecca as influencers in the
film's Press notes according to the
standard at screenings of the film she's
gone further in describing the movie's
horror as being akin to a vampire saying
certainly metaphorically it is a vampire
film it is about what we do when we're
completely boted with something or
someone and I hope it's part of the
classic Gothic tradition where love and
hate are very very close together more
discussing some elements of the film's
plot after a screening at the Academy
Museum in Los Angeles feno went further
into how the vampire metaphor applies to
Oliver according to deadline her
comments highlighted how Oliver tends to
quote absorb the qualities of life he
desires from those around him the way a
Vampire Sucks a mortal's blood for them
Parts the CN do the same to other
characters in the film possibly the
clearest example of this behavior is
El's conflicting treatment of her
troubled friend Pamela throughout the
film Pamela died yeah should do anything
for
attention as reported by gold Derby
fennel explains her biggest goal for the
film following another Awards
consideration screening in Los Angeles
speaking in a Q&A moderated by varieties
Clayton Davis she said that she wants
each person who views the film to feel
something about it even if they don't
outright enjoy it she explained hate it
love it be turned on be freaked out
whatever it makes you feel I want people
to feel something that's the reason you
make a movie and not a TV show or write
a book speaking with Movie Maker fennel
elaborates that the large amount of
nudity and sexual scenarios throughout
the film were also intended to invoke an
unexpected reaction she explained that
the onscreen nudity is about quote grief
or Triumph as opposed to eroticism for
this reason the regular sex scenes in
the movie are focused mainly on the
actor's face
while the actual nudity comes at more
emotionally cathartic points of the film
such as Oliver's Behavior at Felix's
grave or his Victorious dancing after he
claimed saltburn for his own whether
fennel successfully conveyed these ideas
to our audience is up to the viewer but
with some of the most shocking scenes
and imagery to hit the screen this year
saltburn is sure to bring about to
reaction and just about Anyone who puts
it
on